venite a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono che dio sono vari geni oggi siamo
su bloc party entrance che sarebbe il
dlc di red dead se no vi ricordate cosa
grande ed era perché 20 ragazzi quel
gioco dove tu eri uno zombie che bello
che somma e devi arrivare alla fine del
percorso senza essere completamente
mutilato potevi staccarti la testa
lanciarla importante arrivare al check
point ma ok ragazzi iniziano con easy
start che sarà ecco è fatta primisi
stata una minchia
ok che figo per ricorrere puoi anche
perdere gli arti da cos'è uno zombie
l'importante arrivati l'importante è non
incazzarsi ragazze portate ragazzi e
raggiungere i check point poi tanto
ripartiamo sempre da lì tranne per il
fatto che adesso ciò le vite limitate
porca vacca laida sono carico non
sarebbero tante ricette dai punti da
schifosa che poi effettivamente poteva
fare così già da prima intenzione ma
lancia l'ha fatto sei stupido lancia zio
cantante lancia porca eva salta e lancia
non è di non era difficile anche prima
perché non ci sei riuscito ecco ok ok
perché aranci solo quando hai voglia
cioè io non lo farà ci ho messo una vita
per guarda come è finito il livello tra
ci ho messo una vita in mezzo la fia sta
roba che è una cagata e dai visi start e
pensa a come sono quelli dopo io parlo
beh io non ci credo mai più piccolo
tasto per girare la testa il tuo nonno o
i problemi ai nel non tirate questo il
tasto per tirarla è questo la tv era
così sto gioca la golena le fila del
lucera che mi è venuta per finirlo una
rete idea cioè quando ho finito
ringraziato di gesù lawrence di calabria
quando l'ho finito tempo fa ha
ringraziato veramente il cisu perché non
ne potevo veramente più di un gioco del
genere ho giocato solo adesso perché è
passato più di un anno e quindi non mi
ricordo bene che cosa proprio cerca di
mantenere la carta tutti quanti però
report caputo faccio strisciando non me
ne frega na sega scherzavo raja non mi
ricordo le trappole questo problema di
from porca eva lercia schifosa che
tempismo da polipo briaco ok ok
no ok
se fosse stato così ai tempi non avete
da registrate che avrei tirato giù non
ce l'avete l'idea tre minuti e 59
ragazzi per un livello da deficienti
bossman 2000 m allegro la serata un
reality show ci stanno riprendendo le
loro schiavizzano gli zombie per fargli
fare questi percorsi ostacoli alla
takeshi's kastel e poi li mandano in
onda cioè questa è la loro coppe tutti
che sono diventato un fenomeno tutto un
tratto ai a herat è una sorta di
takeshi's cast e l'oro l'ora che ci
penso
[Musica]
ok no no perché non ce l'ho sempre fatto
perché non lo fa più porca eva anch'io
vabbè se sta in piedi fermo lo fai
occhio perché la baia è striscia meno
male che mi ha tagliato le gambe a volte
un vantaggio non avere le gambe perfetto
questo non so se riesco a farlo senza
gambe però ci provo però non vi prometto
niente regali
ok ok perfetto non ci posso credere non
ci voglio credere
sono riuscito a farlo senza gambe siamo
quasi alla fine tra l'altro lega aveva
fatto non sono stati sotto malaga il
fatto di nara le gambe fantastico hawaii
ea breve
che figata ci posso credere suscita
questo l'ho fatto in meno tempo degli
altri come è possibile
cos'è sta roba questo appena visto
allora piano con la pienezza si risolve
tutto ragazzi [ __ ] eva sono milo
sonino kirby contro il dio non sto
facendo ma per ora va bene non ci posso
credere non ci posso che son riuscito a
farlo colate è questa questa vita in
camera non di mercato
ora che sono umano ma è lo figata
bastasse le ruote sia staccata e non
funzionava così una volta avrà sicuro
hanno tarato sui livelli male
alemanno fa dovrà tener conto che con la
testa staccata più facile
porca vacca ho fatto tutto livello quasi
tutto livello con la testa come faccia
passava lancio la testa per forza non la
posso la lancia ha però ma cosa fai da
te ha dei problemi di fondo socio perché
la trista passa ovunque che però non
riesco a lanciarla non capito per quale
motivo per ora grazie della musica
allegra di sottofondo che mi mette così
mi tranquillizzi tantissimo andiamo a
piedi di mortacci della destra che pola
perfetto cos'è sta roba accessi così di
poteri cliccare non mi ricordo per quale
motivo però boh
ciao zio quante allegra orca vacca sono
ancora di roma scherzavo non sono per
credo di essere morto adesso è finito
beethoven disegnavano una ferita però
convinto arca cipro stai calmo ok occhio
occhio che non vedo dove si va telenor
che ride e difficilissima st parte è
checa singer perfetto la testa jolo gli
olo forte sega non ci credo ecco che si
riparte lo lanciamo
lanciati da sola va bene apprezzo il
tentativo occhio adesso e occhio prima
ce l'hai fatta di farcela
[Musica]
bravo non le braccia maiolo vado lento
come la morte maiolo sono io non le
braccia come faccio la testa alla lancio
è ok ma si arriva [ __ ] ci devo
mettere così tanto c'era spiegare una
cosa veramente ridicola non ci sono
state brave belle le gambe zio lancia
lancia st testa per l'amore di gesù
guarda la guarda lasciamo perdere non
voglio neanche commentare questa cosa la
voglio commentare neanche direi che
fosse visto che sta diventando
leggermente difficile facciamolo nel
prossimo episodio io qua concludo perché
con sta roba dire che possono concludere
qui saranno dodici ore di registrazione
dovrò ridurla in qualche modo però
faccio perché sono morto un miliardo di
volte che voi non avete visto però o
tagli o taglio isti lido e tanto anche
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
al solito ti piace il momento non mi
piace anche vari social che come
descrizione se ne sono visti siete noi
ci vediamo al prossimo video e da
ragazzi
[Musica]